First, we'll talk about inter-rater reliability. First, the rater has to know
the ratee well ,for a long period of time and have observed the person in many
different situations. Second, ideally we would have many different raters rate
the personality of an individual to reduce or avoid bias. With children or even
animals who cannot read their own personalities we need to have observers rate
personality. Traits such as introvert, extravert, anxious, worrying, friendly,
warm and dependable for example, have particular behaviors associated with
them. But rating other people's personality is not as simple as it may first
seem. As we just mentioned, the rater must know the person well, and we need
inter-rater reliability, that is, consistency between different raters. For
example, if someone is deemed hostile by one person and friendly by another
person, then we do not have a reliable reading of personality.